I knew that something was wrong I wasn't
able to work I wasn't creating anything
and a lot of these obsessions I was
having were sexually themed
you don't want to tell anybody this
stuff
you have no choice but to suffer in
secret
I'm Martin I'm 32 and I've got OCD
[Music]
all through uni I didn't have any
troubles I went through film school
learning how to tell stories and making
people laugh I had the best friends
I just fell in love for the first time
it's great
obsessive compulsive disorder or OCD is
where you have uh intense obsessions
about something and then you try to make
those thoughts go away or try to feel
better by doing compulsions
you can get obsessed with anything for
me it was sexual stuff it was questions
about who I am usually like negative
questions what if I am a dangerous
what if I've been born with some you
know
something wrong with my brain that makes
me a pervert or for lack of a better
word evil
at the time I didn't see it as a health
problem
I had this weight that I was dragging
around everywhere
and
that no one else knew and that I could
never tell anybody
you read the description of OCD and you
think well I'm not doing any compulsions
but trying to unthink a thought negate a
thought trying to solve a thought what
we call rumination those are all
compulsions
so sexuality which should be positive I
had attached fear to I totally abandoned
sex I didn't masturbate for for six
years there was a time I couldn't even
touch
my penis to go to the toilet
even something that unsexual I couldn't
do
years later my OCD pivoted into
contamination concerns and my hands were
bleeding because I was scrubbing them so
much
the washing of the hands compulsion is
exactly the same as the rumination
compulsion uh it's just it's all
happening invisibly and so you don't
think it's there
it was about eight years before I
managed to say any of this out loud
even being diagnosed as
OCD doesn't make the doubt go away
medication gives you some sort of
support so that you can then
do the work
it's taken many years of therapy and
like changing my relationship to my
thoughts to get to the point where I
don't take my thoughts as seriously as I
did thoughts are not threats feelings
are not facts
I discovered as time went on that the
more you talk about it the less power it
has the reactions from people in my life
friends family my bosses
has been 100 positive and not at all
what I feared
talking about OCD and creating things
about OCD has become like an obsession
for me in a good way this time that's
become a new great purpose of my life at
least at this time of my life is to use
my passion for for storytelling to try
to tell this very Untold Story
people can live in that black hole
period for for decades before finally
getting the diagnosis and I want to save
other people from going through that if
if they can
now that I'm on the upside of recovery I
feel like I'm making up for lost time
I'm able to
go to my parents house for dinner I'm
able to do something as simple as go to
the Loo I'm able to oh my God go on a
date which is ridiculous
a big part of therapy and Recovery is
trusting myself enough to love again and
it's a constant daily uh battle
uh
but I'm working on
[Music]
if you can relate to anything I've said
or if you recognize any of yourself in
what I've been talking about please give
a click to the link that you'll find in
the comments or give a Google to OCD
there are plenty of resources out there
if you just look
thanks very much
take care